we have more now with dr mark siegel a
fox news medical contributor nyu langone
health professor and medicine
of medicine and the author of the book
covid the politics of fear
and the power of science dr siegel
always good to see you
and get your perspective you know we've
heard one of the reasons why this new
strain is so concerning
is about how fast it can spread we know
that about covet 19
too it seems so first how exactly is
this different what can we do about it
well laura people out there need to be
reassured by the fact that viruses
especially this kind of rna virus are
always
changing always mutating and when we
hear the word mutation we get scared and
we get worried
but the truth is it's happening all the
time and this particular strain
which has multiple changes has been
around since october in the uk
and it has spread to some neighboring
countries it's been in netherlands it's
been in denmark it's even gotten as far
as italy and australia
but it's probably here in the united
states the london school of hygiene and
tropical medicine says
that it's about 56 more contagious
but you know what that's a mathematical
model we don't know for sure and one
thing we don't do enough of
is laboratory testing to see about
different strains
so that's why i'm glad to see that la
county is doing that right now
yeah you know i wanted to ask you about
your assessment on la county
because you know christina coleman's
report showed some alarming stats there
as we look at the tally on thursday
alone state officials there saying the
rate of acceleration
has gone beyond any model and
expectation that they've had so
could it be a double whammy of cobit and
this new strain or what do you think is
happening there
well first of all that's possible and
there was 13 600 new cases
thursday alone which is exorbitant but
so far testing genetic testing hasn't
shown
that it's that strain if it were that
strain i again want to reassure people
that
as these viruses mutate over the course
of a pandemic they tend to become more
transmissible laura
because they want to survive if they end
up in the host at a dead-end host and a
person dies they don't spread so they
tend to become more transmissible but
they also
tend to become less virulent meaning
that they're not as deadly that they
don't cause as much severe disease and
there's no evidence
with this london strain whatsoever that
it makes people sicker
and the same it's true true with a
vaccine it tends to
really be covered by by these vaccines
what are we calling it dr
siegel i've read that it's b117
um and that it has you know as you
mentioned the mutations and the
mutations are different
uh but maybe we shouldn't be alarmed
because as you're saying that this is
something that happens anyway
so first of all what are we calling it
so when we read it we know what we're
talking about here
um and and can it be you know is the
vaccine that we're hearing about here in
the united states the fisa the moderna
is it going to protect against this well
the
the name you just gave for it is right
the b117 mutate that's a
it's about 20 mutations that have
occurred but some of them are to that
surface protein that we're looking at
despite protein that we target the
vaccine
for but all the vaccine scientists are
saying the same thing laura
it would take so many changes to that
surface protein
before it would affect the vaccine the
vaccine is magnificent
in that and i'm talking about the pfizer
and the modern vaccine specifically the
ones we have out now
they actually go for multiple targets on
that
on that protein causing an enormous
robust immune response almost
zero chance that it would affect vaccine
coverage at this point
all right well we'll take that dr mark
siegel thank you so much for being with
us today as always
great to hear your perspective see you
soon thank you